[Musique]
étranger
salut john as-tu fait un bon voyage
euh ça a été une dure journée de nuit c'est
tout ce que je peux dire
où étais-tu quand je t'ai inventé dans
ce spectacle
quelque part dans les champs de fraises la
raison pour laquelle je
t'ai invité c'est parce que tout le monde
parle d'une
reformation possible des beatles qu'est ce
que tu en penses
tu n'avais pas besoin de me faire venir
ici tu sais parce que euh
georgia t'a dit que george harrison a dit
que
tant que john est mort
il n'y a aucune chance que les beatles se
remettent ensemble  encore ouais jamais
mais ils disent que la reformation
aura lieu avec ton fils julian chez toi
que penses-tu de ça ça fait partie
il fait partie de moi ouais il est
tellement un clone de moi tu sais ouais tu
veux le voir chanter
ouais  ok elle
[Musique]
soleil nous sommes un milliard d'
enfants réunis
donc quand j'entends parler du trou dans le ciel
nous escaladons la plus haute montagne
nous ferons exploser le désert
[Musique]
mais quand j'entends comment les forêts sont
mortes
[  Applaudissements]
euh s'il est question que les beatles
jouent à nouveau ensemble,
c'est parce qu'il y a eu une scission et quand nous
disons scission,
tout le monde pense au yukon ou pourquoi
bien pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi yoko pourquoi pourquoi était-elle
responsable
de la scission des beatles avec qui elle était
juste  moi c'est tout ce qu'elle a fait elle
était
avec moi tout le temps euh à la fin quand
tu vivais dans le dakota à new
york avec elle
il y a un coach ouais ouais toi tu as dit
qu'elle t'a transformé en femme au foyer
comment tu peux bien expliquer moi  je n'ai jamais eu
ça avant j'étais toujours en tournée
partout dans le monde tu sais et euh c'était un
peu comme une sorte de retour à la maison
tu sais cuire du pain et des trucs
comme ça tu sais
euh comment puis-je dire
euh c'était un peu comme un  une nouvelle chose pour
moi qui m'occupe des affaires de sean est-ce
parce que euh
tu étais tu n'avais pas de mère quand tu
étais quand tu étais c'est vrai ouais
ouais elle a été renversée par un policier qui n'était pas
en service
qui a senti un verre au fait tu sais
ouais
et ton  père eh bien il était juste dire
qu'il le  aves
toute la famille a été des rovers vraiment tu
sais euh tu es allé en nouvelle zélande
quelque part tu sais
avec toi tu l'as rencontré après
ouais je l'ai rencontré vers 65 ans tu sais
euh il voulait de l'argent il était un peu
dur tu sais qu'il n'avait pas  beaucoup d'argent
alors euh j'aime bien lui donner de l'argent
et
euh c'était vraiment tu sais ouais
il ne pouvait pas continuer à revenir pour de l'argent
tout le temps tu sais tu dis
que Julian Lennon ressemble beaucoup plus à un
clone de toi
ce fils  tu connais lenny kravitz tu
ne
veux pas le voir ouais
nous avons le petit
est un clone de jimi hendrix n'est-il pas tu
sais ouais et le clone noir de toi aussi
non c'est vrai ouais
euh mick jigger tu veux voir  mick
jagger je préfère mourir d'abord
parle nous du 8 decembre
9 decembre 18 bien j'ai
passé toute la journée avec yoko
puis nous sommes sortis et euh comme d'habitude comme un
groupe de
euh je suis sorti mes fans
encore sont venus près de moi et euh il  avait l'air sympa
il avait l'air
il m'a tendu un de mes disques et euh
j'ai pensé euh
maintenant il y a un regard étrange sur son visage
tu sais
qu'il vient de dire john puis-je avoir ton
autographe est
-ce que tu te souviens de ce que tu as écrit
quelle photo tu as écrite
ouais j'ai écrit john londres 1980.
ça aurait dû être john londres 1940
à 1980 ouais et
n'a  Tu ne sens pas que quelque chose était sur le point
d'arriver
non je ne savais pas euh nous sommes sortis
sommes revenus trois ou quatre peut-être cinq heures
plus tard
et le client a garé la limousine
yoko est sorti le premier a marché dans l'allée
et j'ai senti
que quelqu'un était  en regardant tu sais
en me regardant tu sais donc j'ai juste regardé
autour de moi et
j'ai vu ce gars se tenir là avec une arme
à feu dans une sorte de positionnement militaire
tu sais ouais et
c'est tout ce dont je me souviens
ouais cinq balles il t'a tiré dessus
je  je ne me souviens de rien à ce sujet il a
dit je ne voulais pas tuer john lennon je
veux tuer je voulais tuer une pochette de disque
eh bien la pochette de disque est toujours là mais
je ne suis pas là tu vois ce que je veux dire
alors euh ça  Guy Chapman
sortira de prison ici 2  000 veux-tu le
rencontrer
j'ai dit que nous étions aussi populaires que euh christ
je n'ai jamais dit que c'était comme
mal interprété
ce que j'ai dit je suis aussi cool que le pape
peut l'être tu vois ce que je veux dire
[Musique]
bleu